hi there steve here and uh
i'm gonna do two things today first of
all uh thank you for the responses to
the uh polls that we did
and you'll see here that you can
look in the
description box to see the results
it seems to indicate that most people
absorb their vocabulary through lots of
reading and listening
but they mix in a certain amount of
deliberate vocabulary study
and that a lot of people at least those
that responded are able to get in a lot
of listening
now uh there were some questions in
response to the video about listening
there were some questions like how do
you i have trouble listening and what is
the strategy how do we get better at
listening so i want to talk a little bit
about that but i also before doing that
i want to announce for those of you who
are interested that i am moving on from
greek
onto arabic starting today
now i'm going to follow this up with a
little video in greek
just to explain why i'm moving on from
greek and basically what i'm going to
say is the following
and that is that you know in learning a
language motivation is extremely
important so my initial motivation for
learning greek was that my wife and i
had decided to visit crete and
subsequently we also went to athens
and you know originally we're only going
to go to crete and because one of my uh
listing materials and reading materials
was about the building of the acropolis
we extended our visit to go to athens so
here again
that relationship between motivation
and
language travel and so forth motivation
is extremely important i am by no means
proficient in
greek
um i can have simple conversations
uh i can read newspapers or even history
books with the help of link
on my own it's a struggle there are so
many words that i yet have to learn and
i know from experience
that it's a long road and i've said this
before however i have discovered a new
world the world of greek history the
world of the greek language i can read
the alphabet and i can always go back to
it and i won't have lost much and this
is the case with my czech with my polish
with my romanian
i've started sort of on the path of
discovering these languages i can always
go back to it and in fact to any of my
languages i can always go back and
improve but right now i'm more motivated
to see if i can discover a little bit of
arabic and the arabic world now let's
get back to listening what are some of
the sort of suggestions that i might
have for people who who have trouble
focusing or who have trouble
uh listening
i would like to touch on seven points
seven let's get seven up there seven so
first of all
uh you have to
listen
to things that you have a chance of
understanding in my view i think there's
limited benefit to listening to things
that you don't understand so typically
that means access to a transcript
uh at the beginning okay uh later on
when you're good enough at the language
that you can understand 70 80 90
then there's benefit in listening even
without a transcript because you're sort
of refreshing all the things that you
know and you're taking a stab at
inferring or understanding
those things that you don't yet
immediately understand so number one is
make sure especially when you're
starting out that you have access to the
transcript that's point number one
point number two is
listen a lot in the initial stages
to
repetitious material in other words
that's why i like our mini stories
because the vocabulary repeats uh
grammatical structures repeat and then i
listen to them repetitively as i have
said 50 100 times i've listened to them
in the case of greek so listen a lot to
things where it repeats because
a lot of it or some of it you understand
and some of it you don't yet understand
even if you've read it remember we're
listening and reading to the same
material even after reading it you still
don't pick it up when you listen to it
so you have to keep doing that so that's
number two listen a lot and repeatedly
to material easy material hopefully
where there's a lot of repetition of
vocabulary point number three
as soon as possible listen a lot again
to interesting material and remember
always try to have the transcript
available and the reason you want to
listen to interesting material is that
after a while our ability to absorb
things when we when we listen to things
that we've listened to before starts to
diminish so you have to mix in
interesting things where you're actually
interested in
what the subject matter is it might be a
novel it might be a story it might be
history you know sports whatever it is
that you're interested in so
make sure you have the transcript that's
number one
to listen a lot repeatedly to repetitive
somewhat less interesting material but
eventually and as much as possible and
as soon as possible move on to
interesting things that are going to
capture your curiosity so that you're
more focused on the
interest
this you know what it is they're talking
about
than
trying to focus in on words and phrases
and i find that
you know it doesn't matter what i'm
listening to there is a tendency to tune
out sitting in the car working out so
don't expect they're gonna always be 100
focused it doesn't matter you are
bathing your brain with the language
okay
fourth point is read read a lot okay not
only
things that you're listening to but all
reading
is tremendously valuable
in terms of giving you familiarity with
the language introducing vocabulary of
course until we have a large vocabulary
we have to read in my view in an
environment where it's like assisted
reading that's link so
you can look up words you can review the
words immediately after having read a
page at link but you have to read a lot
uh my statistics that link in terms of
the number of words that i have read
like even in greek
it's well in excess i don't know how
many hundred thousand words that i've
read just on link
you have to read a lot reading helps you
understand when you listen if you don't
have words if you don't have familiarity
with the language just listening
listening listening is not enough you
have to read a lot so that was the
fourth read a lot
now
again i mentioned this number five
variety vary the things that you're
listening to remember again we always
want to have that transcript available
until we're fairly advanced but try to
vary it variety is good for the brain
i don't mean three different things
within half an hour i mean focus on one
range of subject matter so you get some
familiarity with the context with the
vocabulary but then
at some other point
do something else and this can be as
simple as when you're starting out
having a variety of beginner material or
later on perhaps having two or three
different kinds of content history
literature whatever that you're
listening so
variety
is important so that's number five
number six
keep listening
don't say well i don't understand enough
keep listening in language learning
progress is slow and number seven keep
reading
there you have it
uh i won't remember all the seven but
the gist of it is keep doing it
vary it mixing the reading and listening
and eventually
your brain will start to focus and
there's no point being frustrated that
you
can't understand or you have trouble
focusing you just have to keep going
it's that simple okay then
that's all i have to say and now i'm
going to try to do a brief explanation
in greek as to why i'm moving on from
greek to arabic bye for now
you